Hi I'm Gabriele and
I'll be your instructor for
this short introduction to Objective-C.
This course is tailored for
Swift developers.
Our goal is to prepare you to dive into
an unfamiliar Objective-C code base and
migrate features from
Objective C to Swift.
We'll be focusing on
the following skills.
[MUSIC]
In lesson one you'll learn
the distinguishing language features
of Objective C.
In lesson two we'll go over
some Objective C syntax and
you'll write some classes and
properties from scratch.
In lesson 3, we'll talk about how
to write and call methods, a.k.a.
send messages in Objective-C.
With these new skills you'll
build a functioning game.
In lesson 4, you'll port the app
GIF Maker from Objective-C to Swift,
focusing on writing custom classes and
incorporating third party frameworks and
extensions and lesson 5,
you'll import more features of GIF
maker from Objective C to Swift
focusing on data persistence
with NSCoder and I NSK.driver.
To wrap things up in less than six,
we'll review the most common challenges
for interoperability between
the languages of iOS and you'll complete
a set of coding challenges to
sharpen your interrupt skills.
[MUSIC]